talk about because in the urban areas
you have the nation of islam and they're
doing some good work you know to me
helping get people off the street you
know giving the bean pies and all that
but now what would you tell someone fair
con for instance he might be watching
the dean show right if you had to sit
down with him you follow me what what
would you say to the nation
you know is this the islam you're
talking about the thing is this
and i'm gonna give
the people just an understanding of what
it is first and foremost to be
african-american in this country
hundreds of years of disenfranchisement
you know i'm saying and continuously to
the day
being demeaned ostracized belittled so
on and so forth
we always needed a sense of belonging
and i'm saying
a sense of
unity
dignity honor all the things that have
been stripped
so what you find
from
my culture
that we will quickly
incline ourselves to anything that we
can forge that can give us that
whether it be
the nation of islam the black panthers
the crips
bloods
gds whatever the case may be
we find ourselves by default
inclined to these
forged brotherhoods or unions
that give us a sense of belonging a
sense of dignity a sense of honor a
sense of purpose
but there's nothing on this planet that
does that for creation
better than islam
unity cannot be established through
nationalism it's been tried
history tells you that it doesn't work
farron tried it he tried to distinguish
a people and raise his own people
and the love put that
plot or that plan to cease
hitler he tried it
[Music]
this is nationalism
doesn't work
subhanallah it doesn't work
because you can't alienate
a mass majority of people and try to
raise one particular group and say that
they're superior
when the law only mentions in the quran
believers and non-believers you don't
put race on anything it's either you die
a believer or you die a disbeliever
there's no ethnicity
and no one owns this um the adams happen
to be the smallest population of muslims
but they're the promotional vehicle for
islam so people tend to believe
especially us as african-americans that
that's out of religion
yeah because the book was revealed in
the arabic language that the messenger
was sent was an adam
but there's not a single messenger that
was sent
there was an english-speaking
messenger
and they did not come
you know saying to us particularly my
culture as a messenger
you know
so
the thing is this
i tell people all the time not to
confuse islam islam the religion of
allah
the religion is for allah
you know saying for the embeddement of
his creation and totality not just one
group yeah don't confuse that with the
nationism
don't confuse that with moral science
don't confuse that with the five percent
is don't confuse that with none of that
because instinctively like i said we
want to gravitate to people that look
like us
you know what i'm saying and this even
resides even amongst islam we're not
free from it
just because we appoint the religion of
truth it doesn't necessarily mean that
nationalism doesn't exist it's a human
deficiency
islam is free from that
this is a human deficiency
islam unites all walks of life
when you see the hard season when
there's five million six million people
making tawaf around the kaaba
you can find young people there
somewhere i don't care where you're from
indonesia malaysia indonesia the largest
population of muslims in the world you
never hear about this
largest population of muslims in the
world
majority of africa a lot of those
countries are predominantly muslim
countries so when you want to chase your
heritage look back to the lands that you
know you your people or your ancestors
came from and you'll find that most
likely today is a predominantly muslim
country inshallah we can we can
encourage people like fair con if they
watch you know because they've they've
made some great steps forward you know
what i mean
taking you know uh certain things and
incorporating them but now going to full
extent like getting rid of certain
things that totally you got this farad
muhammad you know what i mean to make
god yeah i mean that that that saying
that this other uh what's his name
elijah muhammad was a messenger yeah
you know these things
inshallah most people who have come to
true islam they've seen through this but
inshallah we can get some some more
insha allah you know a lot of guys and i
like what you said if you look into the
quran the sunnah and then the
understanding of those best generations
who are living with prophet muhammad how
they
interpret it how they understood it you
can't go wrong
you can't lose yeah you can't lose that
is the correct methodology of islam is
the quran the sunnah and the edgema the
setup the consensus of the settlers and
what they agreed upon you know saying in
the most virtuous generations that
followed the prophet saw he sell them
the best generation is my generation and
those that follow them and those that
follow them so it becomes clear we
understand our religion we don't have no
problems with that i can look to you
you know saying what is your ethnicity
where's your nationality
huh
from bosnia why is two
individuals sitting here as brothers in
islam you from bosnia i've never been to
bosnia i'm from harlem you know what i'm
saying and i'm pretty sure we walk out
the door we'll see someone else from
somewhere else it's muslim and so on and
so forth it's like you can't
make this up
this is not a forged union this is not a
ford unity this is not a fourth
brotherhood allah says
only the believers are brothers only the
believers are brothers
not only the africans
not only the hebrews not only the no
only the believers and brothers so as
long as you believe in your lord in the
last day you believe in his divine
decree you believe in everything that he
created you believe that he created
everything with purpose you believe that
he sent messages and concessions to
nations after nation at the nation and
finally after his mercy out of his mercy
he sent the messenger to all mankind if
you believe that then you fall into this
brotherhood that allah established
only the believers
are brothers